five six seven eight one
two three four five six seven eight
very nice groups
one two three four five
i want to take this from the top guys
okay cool okay
no no no your top just
just your top
okay
five six seven eight
let's stop what
just say it what what yeah we can take
it yeah i'm just trying to think of
terms that'll stick you know wow
okay no no it's not bad it's it's just
not what what we rehearsed got it no
point taken yeah you're making your
point so clear yeah good job good job
for making a point so clear okay let's
concentrate on the movement yeah i would
love to focus on that that's what i came
here to do
here to dance i'm excited
just distribute the weight evenly on
your feet very tight
one two we know you know what i mean
okay let's just take a beat because i
don't think anything i say is going to
get through right now so
everyone
water and snack break
okay wait wait wait i'm going to take a
water and snack break on one side bella
back in line
back in line honestly i think this is
just a matter of not enough rehearsal
try to talk to me in a way that actually
allows me to learn
because i feel completely dragged to the
butt i feel completely alone up here
my hands are tied and i can't dance if
my hands are tied this is not what's
going on here that's gas lighting yeah
that's stuff sliding mama
okay if you're denying our reality if
you're saying that what's happening to
us our lived experience isn't real
that's textbook lighting it actually is
okay because what i see my lived
experience is that riley sorry riley but
you're asleep at the wheel asleep me
yeah yeah you so sloane has her hand up
sloane i think you guys are really good
but you just get in your head maybe
phone son i'm just really glad that your
mom's at jury duty and isn't here to see
this today
[ __ ] maybe we should take a break it
might be good for us to blow up some
steam oh pick me pick me shut the [ __ ]
up cha-cha
girls
this is not a big adjustment and why am
i hard on you because you're good
because you're good
you're better than this yeah yeah
okay i know i know that we have it i
think that i think we're under like a
lot of stress let's actually go now
let's actually go really good to go now
i'm ready
now to two steps two
one
two three four whoa oh my god
[Music]
where the heck did the bubble come from
like it came from the window but like
where would a bubble come from it was
like big and then it came down and no
one touched it and it just popped by
itself
okay guys now get in position let's do
the dance okay okay put this right into
the dance all together
five six seven eight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
yes
yes
john kate that's what i'm talking about
good job everybody
what you're gonna say we could rehearse
at my dad's house tonight and then watch
a movie we could get something from
redbox or even just stream something
yeah yeah
okay
that's a snack
you're so lucky
[Music]
hey bella wait up
[Music]
you